[Music]
this month we are marking 40 years since
the first
hiv aids cases were officially reported
in this country
hiv was first identified in a handful of
patients in california
and has claimed the lives of about 700
000 americans since 1981.
about 1.2 million people in this country
now live with hiv
olympic gold medalist greg louganis
helped bring the conversation around hiv
into the mainstream when he came out as
an hiv
positive gay man back in the 1990s greg
joins us now to discuss greg louganis
it's really good to see you again
it's great to see you welcome back you
know when we first heard about aids way
back in the day
there was so much ignorance and so much
fear among many of us who just really
didn't understand what it was
and i'm wondering what it was like for
you when you were first diagnosed did
you think that it was a death sentence
for yourself
well yeah when i was first tested
it was six months prior to the olympic
games in
seoul in 1988 my thought was if i was
hiv positive then i was going to do the
honorable thing and go
i was training in florida and so i was
going to go back to my home in
california and lock myself in my house
and wait to die
because that's what we thought of hiv it
was a death sentence
and you know doctors are saying get your
affairs in order and all that
but the doctor that i was seeing in
florida my cousin he
said that the healthiest thing for you
is to continue training
and so then i focused all that energy
into
my training and preparing for the
olympics and so that was a much more
positive focus so i think it ultimately
saved my life
and luckily the perceptions have changed
yeah but i think greg
i think there's still a lot of
misunderstanding about this virus
what's your feeling about that
there is i mean i i just got a message
yesterday
from a mother whose son cyril converted
and she said that he's giving up um
because it's so it's so scary and
terrifying
but if you're treated then if you're
[Music]
if you have a undetectable viral load
then you can't transmit the virus
so there's a lot of education that still
needs to happen
we need to continue talking about it
i think that hiv has kind of been put on
the back burner because
it seems manageable and so
uh you know so then it's not at the
forefront
we don't have all of the you know the
the deaths that we had in
in the 80s and early 90s and that people
are
are surviving and so you know just
reaching out to that community
and in lending support there's so many
support organizations out there
who are you know resources that you can
go to
so i think that's really really
important greg it's tony here you've had
such a tremendous career as an athlete
and then
also as an advocate and it's been
recently announced that there's gonna be
a biopic a major feature film about your
life
uh there's a lot in that life yeah what
stands out to you i mean
what would you count it's hard to hard
to itemize but you're your major
accomplishment
it it really is you know it it's funny
i'm you know i'm really happy that
they're doing
this biopic and i think it's going to be
really really incredible
um you know the the made for tv movie
with mario lopez was
was wonderful but um i think we're going
to
take a look at some of the um more
adult topics
who should play greg louganis in this
bio have you casted it yet
i know we're we're working on it you
know uh i haven't heard either so
i hope they're doing their ab work right
now yeah send in your resume
yeah they do greg louganis thank you so
much for joining us this morning